and your father chased you yeah because  i tried to get into the i  tried to go to my car and my girls  literally  blocked the door in my car said dad dad  please you can't no  no no this was the hardest part of the  book to write  and he grabbed me  in a hug and grabbed me  give me bear hug and he said  uh he just cried she said i don't know  what to do  i don't know what to do please did you  what did you think when you heard that  i thought i need to figure out a way  to tell him that i'm going to do  something so that i can go  take another hit yeah it's the only  thing i could think  literally that's how powerful i don't  know if a force more powerful than my  my family's love except addiction  you